Warcraft is directed by Duncan Jones who
made two really good films moon and
source code two films I really enjoyed
so I was thusly excited to see what he
could bring to this world and of course
as you probably know it's based off one
of the most successful video games of
all time world of warcraft it's pretty
much impossible to be a human being that
hasn't heard of World of Warcraft
now I've never personally gotten into
the game so I'm not looking for
fanservice I'm not looking for things
that are going to remind me of my time
playing this game I'm wondering is this
a good film does it work on the big
screen in this film you have orcs and
you have humans and they are at battle a
portal separates their world and
sometimes the Horde of orcs comes
through that portal to steal away humans
because the orc leader has the ability
to suck the energy out of anything
living and he wants to do that to humans
as well as some of his own people
because their land is being destroyed so
a few orcs are starting to feel
rebellious against their leader and
those orcs team up with the humans to
hopefully go against this guy and take
them down this movie is being lambasted
by critics usually I tried not to look
too deeply into reviews before I see a
movie because I don't want anything to
affect my judgment but the reviews from
professional critics are so harsh that
it's almost impossible to drown out that
noise plus it opened in a lot of other
places already I personally don't feel
this movie is as bad as critics are
saying there is definitely some
entertainment value I know the audience
I saw it with did a lot of clapping and
cheering and they were having fun with a
lot of the action set pieces and one of
the strongest things in this film is
Duncan Jones as a director the movie
definitely has some problems and I'll
get into those in a minute but Duncan
Jones did bring a unique perspective to
this video game turned into a movie from
the way he shot the opening sequence
alone I could tell there was going to be
some really cool directorial flare
throughout this film and he shot a lot
of really great battle sequences and for
the most part the CGI incorporated with
the humans does work fairly well there
are a few shots where the CGI was very
noticeable and one in particular word
almost looked like a fan film or Ben
Foster's character who's playing this
wizard called The Guardian
it's an overhead shot he's summoning his
power and then there's this artificial
shake that they inserted into it it
looked really bad for the most part the
motion capture especially from Toby
Kebbell and his
character is really good a plus material
motion capture work and Toby Kebbell
place an orc who's at a crossroads in
his life he's the one who's feeling
rebellious against his leader and by far
that was the most interesting character
in the movie for me he had something
about him that I was invested in I was
actually more invested in him than any
of the human characters which brings me
to my biggest problem with this movie
the human characters I didn't give a
shit about any of them really the main
protagonist is the cool action guy who
really doesn't have much going on I
relate him to Aaron taylor-johnson in
the newest Godzilla movie he's a cool
guy
he's good at his job he has somebody in
his life that he's related to that he
can kind of care for but there really
wasn't that much on the page for his
character he's just a really cool guy
who jumps off tall buildings and you
know kills people really good there's
also a younger wizard in the movie who's
sort of in training who gets a lot of
screen time and I really did not care
much for his character either
Paula Patton in this film plays a
half-breed and you get some sympathy for
her because she is also at a crossroads
in her life similar to the other orc
who's feeling rebellious but her
performance was very mugging at the
camera I like her a lot she's a very
beautiful woman I do think she's
talented but in this film I felt that
she was over-the-top and almost every
scene she was in my biggest issue with
the human characters was Ben foster as
the Guardian he plays this wizard who
for me was just incredibly over-the-top
and almost laughable from time to time
and towards the end of the film
especially it was a lot of Shi Rican
Lamas young I'm my finesse guru dee da
ba da da ba doo ba did that for me his
character really didn't work the human
characters in this film and the story
that they tried to create around them
for me was very weak I did really enjoy
the battle sequences and I thought
Duncan Jones had a really nice visual
touch to this movie and some of the
motion capture work was excellent and
when you judge it on the basis of video
game movies in general it is definitely
above the fold and I do think it's
getting trashed way harsher than it
deserves to be the movie does try to go
in a lot of different directions and
there are scenes that feel totally out
of left field like a random cameo scene
from a celebrity that just feels like
why is that even there there are a lot
of scenes like that unfortunately but on
the battlefield whenever there's an
action sequence this movie is very
entertaining and Duncan Jones did
interject some energy into it it's just
that I don't know if I really care to
really experience this movie again ever
Toby Kebbell from
give the best performance in the whole
movie his character was by far the most
interesting but most of the other
characters just didn't have that much
behind them and that was unfortunate the
movie is entertaining though and I think
World of Warcraft fans will probably
have a fun time watching it it's big
it's allowed there's a lot of fun action
sequences but the story and most of the
characters was disappointing I'm going
to give Warcraft a C+ I personally don't
feel it's a disaster like most critics
are saying there are some good things in
this movie but it was a little
disappointing overall so guys stay tuned
for this weekend because now that I
finally assembled my new background I
filmed my Captain America hilarious 'ti
and that's going to be going up this
weekend I've also filmed three new retro
rewinds that are in the can and ready to
be released as soon as I get them
uploaded you guys are the best look
forward to those thank you so much as
always for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes